[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a ceremony
that is very precious to the city of st.
Louis as we talk about a match that had
so much importance back in the 1880s in
fact in the year 1886 when William
Steinitz defeated Johannes Zook rhetoric
in a match to become the official world
champion it was here in st. Louis that
big games six through nine were played
Steinitz won the first game lost the
next board
he was down by three coming to st. Louis
he won three drew 1 so the match was
even when it went to New Orleans
Steinitz won the match 10 to 5 with five
draws so st. Louis had established the
world chess championship officially and
this is a special spot as sort of
hallowed ground you know for st. Louis
and for the chess world because of the
first official World Championship match
and of course we celebrate that
championship and we're going to have
another one this year with grandmaster
Fabiano
challenging Magnus Carlsen in London how
do you contextualize the time then them
playing that match and you getting your
opportunity right now to be able to play
for a world champ your time yeah I mean
it was a very different time back then
but it's great to see history
commemorated here today and
unfortunately the math will be in st.
Louis this time but hopefully in the
future years and there's only one way to
do that
had to win it and get it back to st.
Louis whoa we like the sound of that sir
it'll stand the test of time and
hopefully stays here for the next
hundred and thirty six years and maybe
we'll have a new banner at some point if
Fabiano brings home the victory Ozzy so
said
[Music]